now how about the mathematics behind
this idea well you may not understand
all the symbols but just to kind of see
what it looks like we wrote down
equations physicists wrote down
equations way back 60s and 70s that were
wonderfully accurate at describing the
forces of nature the non gravitational
force is the electromagnetic force the
weak and strong nuclear forces we've
also written down equations that
describe the particles of matter in
which those forces act like electrons
and neutrinos and quarks the puzzling
thing is this those equations have built
in a fantastic amount of symmetry what I
mean by symmetry is from everyday life
if you have a snowflake
if you rotate that snowflake in the
right way it looks the same even though
you've rotated you've transformed it it
has symmetry if you take a sphere that's
even more symmetric as you rotate a
sphere regardless of what angle you
rotate it through it looks the same
similarly the basic equations had a
built-in symmetry much like that if you
mixed up the pieces of the equations
somehow it all coalesced that the
overall mathematical form stayed the
same the problem was if you wanted to
give mass to the matter particles or
even some of the force carrying
particles we knew how to do that
mathematically but the new mathematical
term looks like this it has a side bar
and a sign at that term if you brought
that into the equations ruin the
symmetry symmetry was shattered
completely went away and without the
symmetry the equations were actually
inconsistent they didn't work any longer
so the mathematical puzzle was to try to
give mass to the particles but not
destroy the symmetry the idea of Higgs
and various others was introduce a new
term one that didn't quite look like a
mass term at first sight one that was
completely symmetric like the others
when you brought this new term into the
equations the equations maintain their
beautiful symmetry but notice that
if that first factor in front of sidebar
side we call it Phi that symbol sitting
in front if that is re-written as say M
plus h where M is just a number then
when you multiply that through look what
happens the M multiplies the sidebar on
the site looks like a mass term and that
M is the constant value of the field
that's permeating space so that
permeating field in this mathematical
guise gives rise to the mass of
particles that's how the mathematical
form of this idea works